blog mas numero 10 io mai avrei pensato
che sei arrivato fino al numero 10 senza
perdere alcun giorno molo detto quindi
molto probabilmente la prossima
settimana non lo so prenderò il colore
non potrò fare niente oggi mi sono
svegliato tardi molto karting e ho
pensato che fosse arrivato il momento di
mettere in ordine la mia vita perché
perché a casa mia c'è il delirio che e
lirio delirio che lirio delirio delirio
torino delirio delirio mega delirio
ho appena fatto una lista di cose da
fare è un vorrei semplicemente farvi
vedere quante sono ora un nuovo questo
coso nel tentativo di non farvi capire
la gravità vorrei giusto selezionare i
bocconcini migliori o da un anno e ceto
fondo rotto da due mesi e mezzo sto
pagando internet che non uso perché sono
passato un altro operatore mi si è
distrutta una finestra sopra e l'ho
lasciata lì da un anno e mezzo perso il
il cosino che apre il cancello del mio
box auto e quindi è da un anno e mezzo
del parcheggio fuori perché non ho mai
chiesto nessuno dei miei vicini di
prestarmi il loro telecomandino per
poter loro donare perché mi vergogno che
altro abbiamo il mio divano il milan
dove da quattro anni non funziona cioè
non ha mai funzionato in realtà io per
il coso sotto e si spacca ho ancora dei
panni sporchi la so perché sia quando a
scalare bene secondo me troppo anche non
lo so di il saio della comunione o uno
scarico distrutto che cosa la cartuccia
di careca di queste sono solamente i
migliori
io direi di mettermi all'opera del
valore di partire subito con la cosa più
facile che la cucina secondi dai cioè
non è terribile alla fine questo è
niente in confronto a quella posso fare
queste sono tutte le razioni di luigi
che beve caffè ma che cazzo devi caffè
perfetto questo è andato settiamo vai tu
sei dentro bella ciao ciao
ok che riprendiamoci i next step una
lavatrice facciamo una lavatrice vai in
finiamo forza non mi serve tendeva a
cosa è piena come no allora 1 e dentro
pazzeschi tre ruote extra schifo abbiamo
sito rossi che bel suono giappone venir
io ok questa roba mi terrorizza decreto
come sveglio sempre isterico dopo che
ciò tutto sto schifo in camera con un
poco di zucchero e la pillola va giù non
ha funzionato
riproviamoci koman che bruciano prestato
lasciamo rosario a lavorare
ciao né c'è ancora rosati che sta
pulendo bravo è bene che era sedato il
momento della rivincita la rivincita
contro tavoletta di accesso ho preso
anche questo tappetino grigio in modo da
far panda mano quindi te che sei tanto
carino mai servito bene addio per una
riflessione questo andrò sconosciuto
sacco di persone mi sono successe un
infinità di cose e agiamo su come
esperienze per l'esperienza brute in
realtà siano tutte quante utili esistono
un sacco di persone che da anche a
esperienze brutte se riescono con frasi
tipo vorrei non averlo mai conosciuto
vorranno aver mai fatto questa cosa
vorrei non aver mai pure non aver mai
fatto questa scelta sbagliata è
impegnato
io credo che esiste un margine un
margine per cui le cose 7 sono a oltre
se in contro le persone ma in realtà
alla fine quello che fai e migliorare te
stesso non essere stato anche un cesso
che puzza quindi straparlando non può
usarlo lavata però proviamo ad uscire mi
sono successe un sacco di cose
quest'anno conosciuto persone
meravigliose e fantastiche così come ho
conosciuto persone che per un po di mesi
mi sono detto cavolo la presenza per i
preferito di incontrarlo e mai ho fatto
di lavori meravigliosi meravigliosi ho
collaborato con persone stupende delle
delusioni anche lì dal punto di vista
lavorativo
eppure ci credete che non cambierei una
virgola chi veramente sono fermamente
convinto ops io veramente sono
fermamente aiuto che ho fatto non ho non
un uomo io veramente sono fermamente
convinto che alla fine tutto quello che
ci capita è un'occasione per crescere
evolverci oppure possiamo veramente
sfruttarla comunali b e concertare
quelle cose tipo non mezzo il tizio
questo quindi il super dell'acido a
posto pure te salone prosegue la tour in
una sala delle scale con una scala
sottobraccio cioè se sono ancora vivo un
miracolo con una videocamera sia
sicurezza domestica 0 e vorrei stoppare
adesso questa videocamera ma non ci
riesco perché tutte le braccia occupate
da tempo siamo arrivati a quelle che io
chiamo la mia più grande sciagura
quindi no puntata costerà sistemare casa
è autore sistemare se stessi complicato
difficile da non tenere lo un sacco un
sacco un sacco gratificante ok vediamo
adesso funziona
io inserisco la chiave la chiave
io ti prego no non gira non comporta
come si usa vabbè stare dentro se poi
superati ma sta entrando da che schifo
[Musica]
nono solo dio
oddio tanto della tragedia non come
problema adesso io forse ma commissioni
ma com'è possibile che schifo anch'io
lancio questo qui bloccati no no no
bisogno perché non ti africa non so sto
facendo
oddio ragazzino aperto così spezzassero
chiama un certo punto ho detto vai all
in e non lima funzionato ho azzardato
ok aiuto sto calando la scala e sudore
debitore più buono di quello delle
brioches testa spalla baby one ci sta e
ballabile one city ok perfetto con loro
colorato per quanto sia bellissima alla
vista da questo parata vista di questa
roba qui mi provo orrore vedete quando è
chiusa e così lo vedete che si uniscono
quando la pro
la cosa si stacca e di base è questa qui
si ribalterebbe completamente attorno a
quel perno sasso fatto vedere qualcosa
quest'anno aggiustato quello con il
miracolo si aggiusterà io già one se
rivedremo domani per reato il momento di
scrivere nel gruppo del condominio che
mi fa molto ridere il fatto che c'è un
gruppo del condominio c'è la svolta sono
venuto a scoprire che esisteva un gruppo
del condominio quando su instagram un
giorno nei di m
è uno scritto che è casa mia si era
allagata da erano nei miei vicini
presente è andato al milan nella polpa
polpa alla pompa ciò fa mese vede il mio
balcone si è staccata completamente
cominciato a riempire a riempire il
balcone come una vasca di non c'era in
tutto questo è stato un bel rientro ma
devi sono stato aggiunto in questo
gruppo e da allora ho paura a scrivere
formuliamo quindi la richiesta per il
telecomando del cancello
l'ho perso un anno e mezzo fa in vacanza
ed allora io non sono mai più entrato
nel box auto ma parcheggio xi in giro
come i gitani previsto che il mio box
auto sardi po cagate pisciato gatti sono
uno schifo per aver a un altro giorno
allora ciao ragazzino è troppo
ciao a tutti così ciao a tutti il mio
telecomando del cancello automatico si è
rotto così qualcuno potrebbe prestarmi
il suo tempo per fare una propria e poi
lo riporto uno di questi giorni non
voglio mettere fretta
ok lo mandato scopriremo che cosa
rispondono fra colpo logica
grazie mille
esso corrisponde un perfetto mi ha
risposto mastro che non so chi sia che
carino grazie
vabbè domani la prende perché adesso ce
la farei in tempo è anche questo ciao ne
vado adesso a prenderlo così lo crono e
ciao e questa veramente fatta ciao ok
sono entrati in possesso del
telecomandino magico adesso devo
solamente di può trovare un ferramenta
che cloni questo telecomandino magico ti
prego dimmi che cloni il telecom
ti prego qui ho un telecomandino magico
è un altro telecomandino magico sono
contentissimo perché praticamente lo
facevano e quindi niente adesso questo
meraviglioso telecomandino magico
solamente che è un pochino più
omosessuale credo di questo decisamente
no non ci siamo fatti un problema
parlando di telecomandi ciò questo
telecomando tv che credo sia scarico da
almeno otto mesi e non ha ormai
sostituito le batterie perché non le ho
mai fosse dove è di un galvanizzante
mettere in ordine la propria vita
specialmente quelle cose che hai
procrastinato veramente per secoli che
ti fa sentire vivo ti fa sentire che
finalmente hai un potere decisionale su
quello che ti capita
credici allora lo chiamavano siete
batterio ok caso ha fatto che ho fatto
mantenendo anche una dignità 13 e anche
questa è fatta
zone ad essere a del momento che che più
mi pesa anche quello in cui potrei o
trasformare questa giornata e la
giornata migliore del mondo o
distruggermi casa e rovinare tutto
quello fatto fino adesso mi devo
attaccare un lampadario ma non in
maniera normale in maniera complessa per
me preme beta io ho quel buco lì nel
coatta cane lampadario che è esposto dai
secoli ma devo mettere uno stoppino in
realtà sopra il tavolo in modo che
scenda da sopra il tavolo che potrebber
ente si è un lampadario molto bello
della kartell vissuto quello di un altro
lampadario che ho comprato anni fa
perché quello della carta e mai
utilizzato questo ce l'ha però non
scherzo da quattro anni imbustato mai
mai attaccato per paura di non farcela
cerchiamo di sfondargli come socio perso
un pezzo
infine ha fatto se avevo davanti agli
occhi fino a qualche mese fa aiuto lo
sto cercando avevo un quarto d'ora non
lo trova da nessuna parte
questo vorrà dire che kampala rioni
batte che non riuscirò a montare quella
di lampadario 10 mar il lampadario mi
sento un fallito non diamoci però più
finti andiamo ad aggiustare lo scarico
del cesso al cesto scarico che perde in
maniera assurda e ho provato a montarlo
smontarlo giocare con questo è niente ma
secondo me devo andare a dire a lavorare
con quel galleggiante ore non so perché
sono diventato di colpo un blog di
idraulica però facciamo cioè tutti una
ragione teniamoci stretti per mano e
gridiamo alleluia
funzioni in pop suppongo che la prima
cosa da fare sia quella di bloccare
l'acqua così si blocca siro bloccata ma
che succede
ma perché faccio con un rifiuto ok non
esce più acqua e adesso un po così acuto
di grande raga tagli una ricarica derby
non ci credo anche questa smesso di
funzionare cerci guardiamo tutti come
era prima attraverso e bloccato di nuovo
c'è una presenza is beetle così alta che
secondo me potrei far partorire una
donna in due istanti per quanto
lubrificante c'è anche no come non detto
sta usando le chiavi e sbagliata bene
così perché la proton fighters team
yamaha concluso niente quindi proverà a
seguire un tutorial di quante volte ho
visto sto video di questo quello già
fatto ormai su un genio di questa roba
qui come attaccare questo coso romeno
molto giusta come se fosse una cover del
nokia vecchio ma ci provo ancora lì un
tubo che è uscito fuori e questa roba
qui ragazzi è la roba più piena di
calcare nella storia delle robe piene di
calcare ottobre la pistola di star wars
che mischiano e si ricorda che esistono
lavando sto coso con l'aceto tiro lo
stasera vado a cena ne prenderanno
l'open condimento dai starbucks hashtag
bellissimo meraviglioso speriamo
funzioni altrimenti io giuro che ti
prendo e che fondò dal balcone ok
credo di averlo prelevato alimentiamola
dentro rimettiamo tutto a posto che è
mamma mia sono idraulico
ladies and gentlemen ma come ha
aumentato quello ladies and gentlemen
[Applauso]
maniero va bene va bene ciao né ok
dobbiamo ancora standar e lo abbiamo
quello lì
e adesso andiamo a continuo dai ecco che
no scherzo stars funzioni non mandava di
uscire sotto zero lo verso domattina lo
giuro inoltre ancora fare lui
questo quadro però il pezzo devo
togliere loro insomma un sacco di casini
con le luci fondamentalmente prima di
chiudere questo video però vorrei terno
morale e la morale le cose impossibili
in realtà sono composte da tante piccole
cose difficili che si scompone ancora di
più sono composte da cose mediamente
difficili che si scompone ancora di più
sono composte in realtà da cose facili
tranne montare un lampadario e votare
quelli e fare le cose che non ho fatto
che molto probabilmente farò fra due
anni e con questa nota di tristezza che
ti spinge quasi a voler aprire la
finestra e provare il salto nella fede e
assassin's creed
io vedo una buona notte e soprattutto vi
do un appuntamento sempre domani alle 14
con un altro club basse